ja kaum steht der koalitionsvertrag
schon gibt es breaking news gestern noch
respekt und harmonie bei der vorstellung
der neuen ampel koalition heute offenbar
schon personal zoff und zwar bei den
grünen für den nachmittag war die
verkündung der grünen ministerinnen und
minister erwartet worden aber
wir sind ein bisschen anders aus den
koalitionsgesprächen rausgegangen in den
re sortierungen als wir gedacht haben
und ein bisschen müsst ihr noch warten
wir beschließen nachher im parteirat die
einleitung zur abstimmung über den
koalitionsvertrag
der koalitionsvertrag sieht vor morgen
früh werden dann auch die namen hinter
den verhandelten ministerien dort
auftauchen das wird dann gleich genießt
in den gremien beraten und dann
beschlossen werden das alles
zusammengenommen bringt mich und bringt
den puck dann nicht mit freude dafür ist
die zeit zu ernst nicht mit begeisterung
aber
mit einem ernsthaften stolz vielleicht
über das erreichte zu sagen lasst uns
deutschland regieren und bitte stimmt
für den koalitionsvertrag vielen dank
ein großes thema bei den grünen die
ministerposten und darüber wollen wir
jetzt sprechen mit bildpolitik
chefreporter peter thiede der nämlich
bei den grünen heute beim bund länder
rad vor ort war bitter was ist los
hinter den kulissen
es herrscht ein blutiger machtkampf also
man muss einfach festhalten die grünen
haben nach ihrem verstolperten wahlkampf
nach dieser komplett verkorksten
kanzlerkandidatur von annalena baerbock
jetzt auch den staat in die
ampelkoalition
gründlich versaut es sollte eigentlich
heute abend sollte die mannschaft
vorgestellt dann sollten die fünf grünen
minister vorgestellt werden doch kurz
vor 4 dann die hiobsbotschaft es knallt
es rappelt in der kiste und man kriegt
die ministerien nicht zusammen cem
özdemir da eigentlich nicht mehr gesetzt
war für ministerposten hat sich aber
tatsächlich reingegrätscht und hat anton
hofreiter einem parteien linken damit
rausgehauen aus dem aus dem grünen
kabinett anton hofreiter sollte
eigentlich agrarminister werden das soll
jetzt stützen wir werden damit ist das
gesamte machtgefüge bei den grünen
wirklich durcheinander geraten dass sich
statik ist zerbrochen weil ein realo wie
cem özdemir rhein ein linker wie anton
hofreiter raus das heißt dann auch für
die anderen die das gesetz gehalten wie
katrin göring eckardt zum beispiel dass
das alles nicht mehr funktionieren kann
wenn also ein realo reingeht muss ein
anderer realo raus und der die realo die
dafür rausgeflogen ist ist die partei
prominente ist katrin göring eckardt es
herrscht wirklich ein blutiger
machtkampf bis jetzt ist sie nicht
entschieden der parteivorstand hat einen
kompromissvorschlag gemacht danach
bleibt cem özdemir drin aber das wird
anton hofreiter das werden die
parteilinie auf keinen fall auf sich
sitzen lassen das können sie auch nicht
auf sich sitzen lassen anton hofreiter
ist hier angekommen wirklich wie ein
vagabund in einer zerschlissenen jeans
mit einem merkwürdigen mit einem
merkwürdigen pullover und mit einer
ausgebauten alten lederjacke der gesamte
auftritt sagte eigentlich ihr könnt
nicht mal und das ist wirklich die
grünen stürzen sich ins chaos die grünen
verstolpern den an gestaltung peter und
das besondere ist ja die grünen
mitglieder müssen ja nicht nur über den
koalitionsvertrag abstimmen sondern auch
über die postenverteilung wenn ich das
richtig sehe
ja aber es geht vor allem geht es um die
annahme koalitionsvertrag das andere ist
damit rangekommen entscheidend ist bei
der urabstimmung jetzt über zehn tage
läuft das heute der digitale auftakt
darf dafür
und da ist die posten postenverteilung
drin aber das entscheidende ist der
koalitionsvertrag
morgen früh soll wahrscheinlich dann
ganz unspektakulär auf grünen de dann
die kabinettsliste veröffentlicht werden
so man sich dann heute nacht einigen
kann aber das sind ist blutig das wird
blutig und das da werden narben und auch
offene wunden bleiben so etwas verzeihen
sich die flügel hier nicht das hat schon
seit langem gebrodelt hinter den
kulissen weil die parteiführung wirklich
nach ansicht zumindest des linken
flügels gekungelt hat bis sich die
balken bogen dann hat cem özdemir heute
noch mal darauf hingewiesen dass ihm
robert habeck ja schon vor geraumer zeit
versprochen hat du wirst was jam und
november aber nicht mehr auf der liste
drauf und da und da dass ich jetzt
reingegrätscht er hat natürlich auch die
karte gezogen dass er
migrationshintergrund hat die 18 uhr
vielfältigen grünen hat nämlich schlicht
und ergreifend niemanden mit
migrationshintergrund in ihrem kabinett
drin es waren die
wahl der frauen proporz war erfüllt
links und real oval füllt aber der
migrations proporz zeit nicht und so
wird schempp sie mir eigentlich ein
außenpolitiker ist oder vielleicht noch
innenpolitiker ist der zum schluss im
bundestag verkehrspolitik gemacht hat
nun sein viertes fachgebiet kriegen und
zwar die landwirtschaft da ist ja bisher
noch nicht aufgetaucht man darf gespannt
sein wenn es denn klappt cem özdemir und
die deutschen bauern wird auch eine
lustige kombination aber bei den grünen
ist kein wir nach lachen heute sollte
eigentlich sein friede freude eierkuchen
und wir sehen friede freude pustekuchen
vielen dank peter dass du für uns vor
ort fast und wir werden natürlich dran
bleiben und dann mal schauen was die
grünen damen morgen veröffentlichen
was denken sie über die neue
ampelkoalition die deutschland bald
regieren wird die meinungsforscher von
insa haben im auftrag von bild gefragt
was sie von den versprechen und vorhaben
der regierung scholz habeck berbalk und
linden erhalten die im koalitionsvertrag
gestern vorgestellt wurden genau und da
wollen wir jetzt mal reinschauen denn
wir haben die umfragen natürlich für sie
hier vorbereitet und bei uns im studio
ist dann zu nämlich auch noch bild
chefreporter hans jörg vehlewald und wir
sehen hier schon die erste umfrage das
denkt deutschland über die ampel wie gut
oder schlecht finden sie den
koalitionsvertrag von spd grünen und fdp
insgesamt 55 prozent finden ihn gut 30
prozent finden ihn schlecht und zehn
prozent davon sogar sehr schlecht kann
es ja wie ist das einzuordnen zehn
prozent finden ihn wirklich sehr
schlecht es ist schon
man muss man ehrlicherweise zugeben 177
seiten hat der eine oder andere der
befragten möglicherweise noch nicht fünf
vorne bis hinten durchgeackert das heißt
da das was bisher berichtet wurde über
diesen vertrag darauf hat darüber haben
sich offensichtlich zehn prozent so sehr
geärgert dass sie sagen das wird kann
alles nichts werden mit diesem vertrag
und diese ampel koalition man muss
gucken 55 prozent sagen das ist im
prinzip offensichtlich was ordentlich
und haben wir so einen guten eindruck
hinterlassen und ich glaube das ist
einfach
schlussfolgerungen aus der einer ganz
guten arbeit die diese ampel colette
koalitionäre die verhandler bisher
gemacht haben wir auf die nächste frage
hansjörg die frage war glauben sie dass
die neue regierung der solar stolz als
bundeskanzler er bessere oder
schlechtere arbeit leisten wird als
angela merke dass scholz gleich gut
arbeitet sagen 40 prozent der hat sicher
auch mit der raute als wort setzer
gezeigt dass er schlechter arbeitet
glaubt 28 prozent dass er besser
arbeitet glauben aber auch nur 20
prozent da deine einschätzung
also ich finde eigentlich erstaunlich
dass ich ja sagen wir mal alles in allem
38 68 prozent sagen so ungefähr unter 60
prozent sagen so für ein ungefähr gleich
wie bei merkel oder es wird sogar besser
werden das ist ein ganz schöner
vertrauensvorschuss den er hat das ist
vielleicht auch dem zu schulden dass er
bislang schon vizekanzler waren bislang
einen ganz ordentlichen eindruck auf die
menschen gemacht hat und wenig skandale
zumisst laute und durchschaubare
skandale produziert
immer eher weniger gesagt wir wollen auf
die dritte insa umfrage gucken die
hierfür bild produziert wurde finden sie
es eher gut oder eher schlecht dass die
koalition aus spd grünen und fdp plant
den mindestlohn auf 12 euro zu erhöhen
81 prozent finden das gut und zehn
prozent nur schlecht da sind sich die
deutschen fast einig sind sie sich sehr
einig ich glaube da spielt natürlich
eine rolle dass momentan die inflation
wirklich in aller munde ist leute merken
dass die preise steigen und dass das
gute alte motto der spd ist ließ der
einfachste wahlkampf zu machen einfach
löhne rauf und mieten runter das kommt
immer bei den leuten an das merkt man ja
auch einen 80 prozent wollen gern mehr
geld haben und ich glaube das ist eine
gute sache andere wichtige frage die wir
auch noch gestellt haben wir schauen mal
auf die grafik findet ihr sehr gut oder
eher schlecht dass die koalition
plant kinderrechte im grundgesetz zu
verankern auch da ein eindeutiges
ergebnis 77 prozent finden das gut zwölf
prozent finden dass schlecht
kinderrechte im grundgesetz zu verankern
das bedeutet das überhaupt konkret in
der konkret heißt es dass alle gesetze
im zweifel noch mal darauf überprüft
werden sollen welche auswirkungen sie
auf kinder haben ich bin kein freund
davon viele dinge in einem grundgesetz
zu schreiben insbesondere da die kinder
natürlich auch ganz normal wie jeder
mensch vom grundgesetz ganz besonders
geschützt werden
ich glaube das könnte man sich sparen
wenn es den menschen aber sehr am herzen
liegt ist es glaube ich zumindest ein
schönes symbol
sagen viele menschen wahrscheinlich auch
als mehr kinderrechte hören sich gut an
das will ich und
hatten auch noch gefragt ob man glaubt
dass insgesamt die neue regierung die
koalition
da haben wir ja dass die künftig auch
opfer häuslicher gewalt
asyl in deutschland beantragen können
das finden 41 prozent gut und 41 prozent
finden es schlecht das ist eine
gespaltene meinung das ist deutlich
gespalten genauso gespalten wie
deutschland eben insgesamt bei der
migrationsfrage bei der asylfrage ist
auch mich auf mich wirkt es auch ein
bisschen seltsam denn logischerweise wie
wir gerade am heutigen tag der an
häusliche gewalt erinnert
gewalt gegen frauen das findet ja auch
in deutschland statt das heißt ich finde
es schwer zu umschreiben dass eine
solche häusliche gewalt jemand anderswo
erleidet dann dadurch behoben sein soll
und kann dass er in deutschland
aufgenommen wird ich glaube das wird
noch viele fragen aufwerfen denn bislang
sind es als kriegs zustände in ländern
oder besondere armut kann auch eventuell
eine rolle spielen wenn es sich
lebensbedrohlich ist aber das sind die
gründe um in deutschland oft kauf
genommen zu werden hans jörg vehlewald
vielen dank